[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur public c'est la 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos experts et pour notre dernière
émission de la saison c'est un bilan de
l'année politique que je vous propose on
reviendra évidemment sur les violences
urbaines laissez-moi le droit de faire
autour de la réforme des retraites la
nomination d'Elisabeth borne à Matignon
et ce remaniement en forme d'Arlésienne
beaucoup de thèmes passionnants à
décortiquer dans une minute et puis pour
notre second débat ce sont les dangers
du sur tourisme que je vous propose
d'analyser la France première
destination mondiale mais certains sites
sont fragilisés par l'afflux de
visiteurs des risques écologiques
évidemment mais aussi économiques
il y a un souci de touristes de tourisme
de masse ce qui veut dire que maintenant
pour se loger ça devient compliqué pour
se garer ça devient compliqué pour vivre
dans le village ça devient compliqué et
ça occupé énormément de place et du coup
les écoles ferment les commerces ferment
et la ville locale en disant il y a 350
personnes qui sont qui sont parties
comment protéger nos plus beaux sites
sans perdre l'attractivité touristique
de la France l'équation et compliquée à
résoudre vous verrez mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est la crainte d'une
nouvelle flambée de violence à
l'occasion des fêtes du 14 juillet quel
est le dispositif de sécurité quels sont
les villes qui ont préféré annuler les
festivités première réponse grâce à
mathiasaraez
c'est un 14 juillet à haut risque auquel
se prépare l'exécutif le gouvernement
mais aussi le chef de l'État redoute une
reprise des violences urbaines alors
Emmanuel Macron en plein sommet de
l'OTAN à Vilnius a tenu à afficher sa
fermeté
s'il y avait quelques débordements nous
interviendrons avec la plus grande
détermination
pour que l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
puissent vivre dans le calme pour
prévenir d'une éventuelle menace un
dispositif de sécurité inédit sera
déployé les nuits de jeudi et vendredi
nous avons décidé de la mise en place
d'un dispositif exceptionnel puisqu'il
s'appuiera pour les 13 et 14 juillet sur
130 000 policiers et gendarmes agents du
ministère de l'Intérieur donc 45000
chaque soir spécialement équipé et
organisé pour procéder à la lutte contre
les violences urbaines selon les mêmes
modes Modus opéranzy que pendant les
quatre jours d'émeutes outre ses
effectifs les forces spéciales du GIGN
du raid et de la BRI seront aussi en
alerte appuyés par des moyens
hélicoptères et des blindés de la
gendarmerie tout cela sans compter les
40 000 pompiers sur le territoire pour
éviter tout débordement certaines
communes ont préféré annuler leur feu
d'artifice une décision inacceptable
pour le président de l'Association des
maires de France David Lisnard mais
est-ce que vous rendez compte du recul
que cela représente que de ne pas
assumer la fête nationale
d'assurer d'assumer la prise de la
Bastille et la fête de la convention
c'est un signe de plus d'un malaise très
profond dans la société française et
aujourd'hui à cause de voyous on ne peut
plus célébrer la fête nationale je crois
que c'est bien plus grave qu'on ne le
pense une annonce que soit être
relativiser Laurent Nunez préfet de
police de Paris et comme le ministre de
l'Intérieur Laura plaisir il y a pas il
y a pas d'instruction du gouvernement ce
sont des décisions individuelles en
nombre extrêmement limité pour limiter
les débordements l'usage et la vente de
tous les articles pyrotechniques dont
les mortiers d'artifice utilisés par les
émeutiers seront interdits jusqu'à
samedi
je prenais tout de suite mes invités
Frank Morel bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
avocat associé chez Flichy Grangé ancien
conseiller social d'Edouard Philippe et
expert emploi l'Institut Montaigne
mélodie mogweb bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes docteur en droit public spécialiste
de l'Assemblée nationale auteur de ce
livre Le Petit guide de l'amendement aux
éditions Pepper L'Harmattan
jean-louisika bonsoir je suis venu
directeur éditorial de la revue de
Terranova la grande conversation et
Laetitia cruppa éditorialiste politique
bonsoir Laetitia bienvenue à vous
peut-être un mot pour commencer sur
effectivement ce symbole Franck Morel
des alors c'est pas partout en France et
dans quelques villes mais quand même ce
symbole de voilà de fait du 14 juillet
annulé
oui c'est les feux d'artifice qui sont
annulés c'est pas forcément les fêtes en
tant que tel je discutais il y a hier je
crois avec un élu local qui me disait
que ils avaient envisagé précisément un
bien plusieurs années sans les feux
d'artifice de les rétablir cette année
et qui se posaient la question justement
à nouveau cette année donc ça date pas
de cette année les questions autour de
des feux d'artifice très d'un point de
vue très pragmatique je pense que c'est
une préoccupation liée à l'ordre public
au regard de ce qui s'est passé il y a
quelques jours moi ça ne me choque pas
et moi les pompiers le bal des pompiers
mais il y a pas forcément de feu
d'artifice dans le bal des pompiers
après c'est la question de l'usage des
feux d'artifice et de détournement qui
pourrait qui pourrait en être fait donc
moi ça ne me choque pas que par rapport
au risque constaté voici quelques jours
avec les émeutes etc on puisse
interroger sur le fait de ne pas faire
de feu d'artifice cette année c'est pas
un drame il y en aura ça reviendra quand
David Lisnard mélodie mogwedi on sait de
voyou une certaine façon comment vous
analysez peut-être voilà le
positionnement politique de David
Lisnard et est-ce que vous êtes en
partie d'accord avec avec ce qu'il dit
[Musique]
c'est une fête
que nulle ne doit pouvoir gâcher sous
quelques prétextes que ce soit la
violence n'a aucune place je dis bien
aucune
dans notre société
si d'aventure
certains
souhaitaient gâcher la fête
je veux dire ici de façon solennelle
claire
que la justice sera au rendez-vous des
obligations qui sont les siennes j'ai
demandé dans une dépêche qui sera
diffusée dans quelques heures
au magistrat une réponse rapide
systématique et ferme Jean-Loup missical
la réponse du gouvernement face aux
émeutes pour l'instant c'est une réponse
sécuritaire il y aura peut-être une
réponse plus profonde sur la politique
de la vie etc etc mais est-ce qu'ils ont
le choix est-ce que c'est la bonne
stratégie est-ce qu'on peut faire autre
chose qu'une réponse sécuritaire dans un
climat comme celui-là je crois qu'il y a
absolument aucun choix c'est-à-dire que
la première chose que vous avez à faire
quand vous êtes un gouvernement c'est de
rétablir l'ordre et c'est ce que demande
les en général les électeurs les
citoyens et là en l'occurrence ils font
une espèce de prévention de discours
préventifs pour essayer de dissuader le
plus de candidats possibles à l'émeute
de faire quelque chose le dans la nuit
du 14 au 15 juillet franchement je
trouve qu'ils sont dans leur rôle alors
peut-être qu'il surjoue un tout petit
peu son rôle du pont Moretti enfin bon
l'avocat est toujours là voilà c'est ça
je crois que votre deuxième partie une
réponse est la plus juste c'est à dire
qu'on oublie souvent dans tous ces
débats sur les émeutes urbaines
l'opinion publique et qu'en pense
l'opinion publique cette majorité
silencieuse que l'on n'entend pas et
quand on interroge dans les enquêtes
d'opinion c'est très clair Thomas la
sécurité c'est l'exigence première de
tous les Français quasiment d'une grande
majorité donc oui bien sûr qu'il faut
rétablir l'ordre d'accord c'est une
mission régalienne mais il y a aussi
écouté ce que demande son peuple et on a
quand même critiqué largement le
gouvernement sur sa surdité depuis des
mois là ou une fois peut-être qu'il
répond au peuple je suis d'accord avec
vous mais il y a quand même une question
qui est qui tourne autour de du silence
ou d'un relatif silence même si on a
entendu Emmanuel Macron prendre la
parole
depuis l'OTAN ce qui est pas banal sur
une situation
intérieure on sait qu'en général on est
président de la République enfin disent
qu'ils veulent l'éviter mais le font
régulièrement bref Jean-Louis le
président de la République a choisi de
ne pas donner
interview après le défilé militaire du
14 juillet sans doute parce que il y a
des crânes de violence ce soir ou demain
soir est-ce que vous trouvez ça là aussi
cohérent bien sûr je trouve ça tout à
fait cohérent il y a des fois où le
silence c'est la bonne stratégie de
communication et je pense que nous
sommes là dans une situation où c'est
clairement la bonne stratégie de
communication imaginons qu'il fasse un
discours autour de la notion d'ordre et
d'autorité et que il y ait des émeutes
dans la foulée imaginons même que l'une
des phrases qu'il prononce soit utilisée
par un certain nombre de gens pour dire
que c'est à cause de lui que le faux
poudre a été remis donc franchement
surtout que en plus il n'a pas grand
chose à dire il faut bien le reconnaître
entre nous et donc
ne pas faire de déclaration le 14 pour
éventuellement en faire une le 15 voir à
la rentrée n'a pas beaucoup
mais quand même il y a pas eu encore de
de gris de lecture ce summène
sociologique de par du pré dans la
public sur ce qui s'est passé après la
mort de Naël sur ces cinq aussi une nuit
des moteurs on l'attend quand même cette
parole d'accord avec vous mais je pense
qu'il est intéressant de mettre en avant
pour la raison de savoir pourquoi on se
pose cette question avec autant
d'acuités on se pose cette question avec
autant d'acuités pour trois raisons qui
sont un effectivement le contexte que
vous venez de rappeler de la mort de
Noël et des émeutes qui ont suivi mais
deux aussi parce qu'on est à la fin de
la période que le Président de la
République lui-même avait fixé à la fin
de la séquence retraite en indiquant que
ben on ferait un point justement à la
fin de cette période dite d'apaisement
entre guillemets et 100 jours trois
parce que on a connu avec des présidents
des prédécesseurs d'Emmanuel Macron une
tradition pendant longtemps de du fameux
interview du 14 juillet et donc ces
trois éléments font que on grossit un
peu le trait et on se dit mais bon sang
pourquoi est-ce que il n'intervient pas
maintenant alors après la politique
c'est l'art de faire des arbitrages et
vous avez donné les termes de
l'arbitrage effectivement c'est à dire
que malgré les trois éléments
commentaires ce que je viens d'indiquer
et bien il y a un quatrième élément de
contexte qui est plus puissant encore
que ces trois-là qui est le besoin de
faire retomber la pression le fait de ne
pas en rajouter par rapport à une
situation qui n'est pas encore fait
formellement calmé mais qui n'est pas
formellement
rester vigilant alors le point après la
question qui se pose après c'est il va
pas parler là mais est-ce que avant la
fin du mois de juillet par exemple il y
aura un élément de prise de parole pas
forcément oral peut-être sous forme
d'interview ou autre est-ce qu'il y aura
des jalons qui seront posés par rapport
aux trois enfin en tout cas à la
question mort de Naël et émeute et à la
question fin de la séquence entre
l'image parce que j'adore prendre des
paris ici sur ce plateau ce sera une
interview de presse écrite parce que
Emmanuel Macron a toujours choisi la
presse écrite quand il est assez agi
d'analyser une situation complexe comme
celle que nous avons vécu ces derniers
mois avec une hypothèse presque
quotidienne régionale on verra si elle
se confirme dans les prochains jours
alors c'est la dernière émission de la
saison pour ce débat 100% poétique je
vous ai demandé de choisir un événement
marquant évidemment vous avez tous
choisi de parler de ces violences
urbaines donc on va commencer par ça
mélodie mcuré peut-être alors c'est
paradoxal ce que je vais vous demander
parce que on se dit on a peut-être le
temps et le recul de l'analyse et en
même temps si ça se trouve et personne
ne le souhaite autour de cette table il
y aura une reprise dans les prochaines
heures quel est votre analyse de voilà
de cette de cette flambée de violence en
France
non mais alors c'est assez compliqué il
y a eu des articles des excellents
articles qui ont été faits dont Jérôme
Fourquet qui a analysé dans le point le
pourquoi c'est-à-dire à la fois bien
évidemment on regarde les centres
anciens centres industriels de pauvreté
des problèmes également d'emploi il y a
beaucoup de chômage des problèmes de
deal et compagnie donc il y a une
explication sociologique qui a été
apportée par pas mal de gens
qui n'est pas mon point fort moi je suis
juriste constitutionnaliste
il y a pas en fait il y a pas de
surprise voilà il y a absolument pas de
surprise du tout la seule chose qu'on
pourrait remarquer c'est qu'il y a une
violence plus importante vraiment qu'en
2005 même quand on regarde juste les
chiffres on a 9000 voitures brûlées là
on en a 12000 en moins de jours on a une
semaine alors que c'était 3 semaines là
on a 700 bâtiments brûlés on voit qu'il
y a vraiment une violence globale alors
il y a des réseaux sociaux aussi qui
sont plus importants que en 2005 donc ça
se propage de façon beaucoup plus
importante et la question c'est vraiment
est-ce que on est vraiment un point ça
s'est calmé ou est-ce une étincelle
suffit de repartir quoi vous avez publié
dans donc dans la revue Terranova la
grande conversation une analyse qui est
très fine et peut-être plus surprenante
qu'on ne le croit de de ce qui s'est
passé peut-être on peut commencer sur la
la géographie de ces de ces émeutes
écoutez oui d'ailleurs je crois que
Elisabeth borne l'a dit aussi dans son
dans son interview on constate que ce ne
sont pas que les quartiers politiques de
la ville qui se sont embrasés et même
que près de 50% des quartiers politiques
de la ville n'ont pas bougé et et près
de je cite les chiffres de mémoire mais
60% des émeutes ont eu lieu dans des
dans des endroits qui ne sont pas
quartiers politiques de la ville
peut-être qu'ils vont préciser pour nos
auditeurs que quartier politique de la
ville c'est ce qu'on appelle les
quartiers difficiles ceux sur lesquels
on investit de l'argent pour essayer de
rénover à la fois d'un point de vue
urbanistique et et social donc déjà
cette géographie des émeutes est
différente de celle de 2005 de façon
assez importante
après ça bien sûr il y a l'âge des des
jeunes qui sont et il y a un chiffre qui
nous a beaucoup frappé qui est celui de
430 bureaux de tabac qui ont été brûlés
qui ont été brûlés et détruits alors
comment vous l'analysez l'analyse elle
est simple c'est c'est les dealers qui
en profitent pour détruire la
concurrence
c'est à dire que la vente de cigarettes
de contrebande est une activité
extrêmement importante un peu partout en
France mais en particulier dans dans ces
quartiers alors à la fois on se on se on
refait ses stocks en payant le bureau de
tabac et en même temps on détruit des
des on détruit des concurrents mais
c'est assez troublant quand on regarde
la nature des bâtiments qui ont été
détruits alors c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance à se focaliser sur les
bibliothèques les écoles parce que ça
c'est profondément choquant mais enfin
les bureaux de tabac c'est aussi
impressionnant
je le lis et je l'entends cette cette
analyse elle est effectivement à la fois
édifiante et et un peu effrayante mais
il y a quand même aussi et ça on l'a
plus analysé Franck Morel la question
des des édifices publics qui d'une façon
ou d'une autre on se drapeau français
affiché et ont été une cible là aussi il
y a quand même des leçons à tirer de ça
oui bien évidemment il y a des leçons à
tirer moi si je devais trouver un mot
pour caractériser cette séquence qui est
un mot assez inquiétant d'ailleurs c'est
le mot radicalisation parce
qu'effectivement par rapport à ce qu'on
a pu constater en 2005 on constate un
phénomène de radicalisation c'est à dire
d'intensification de la violence au sens
où la séquence est plus violente encore
vous l'avez dit qu'elle ne l'était en
2005 c'est des personnes plus jeunes que
les personnes qui étaient concernées en
2005 et à tous les échelons de la
société il y a une radicalisation du
regard sur ce qui se passe
radicalisation des jeunes qui ont
procédé à ses émeutes beaucoup plus
violent en direction des bâtiments
publics radicalisation de l'opinion
publique qui est beaucoup plus encore
qu'en 2005 en besoin d'ordre et de et de
d'actionner le levier sécurité beaucoup
plus que ça n'était le cas en 2005 et
donc c'est assez inquiétant parce que ça
renvoie aussi d'une manière plus
générale dans le champ politique en
particulier on a pu le constater à
diverses reprises à une forme de
radicalisation de l'opinion publique sur
différents sujets qu'est-ce que ça va
donner
de fracturation de la société
notamment à l'époque des gilets jaunes
oui finalement on se rend compte que ces
archipels il existe aussi existe depuis
40 ans dans les quartiers populaires je
partage pas tout à fait cette
je respecte beaucoup le travail de
Jérôme Fourquet mais enfin dire que il y
a une archipelisation de la France
mériterait un long débat et moi je ne
suis pas du tout sur cette sur cette
vision sur cette vision des choses mais
enfin on va aller on va laisser ça de
côté je voudrais juste rebondir sur ce
que vous dites il faut quand même
regarder une un détail qui me paraît
important c'est le fait que les autres
ont duré beaucoup moins longtemps quand
qu'en 2005 et ça c'est très très lié à
au monde dans lequel nous vivons qui est
un qui est le monde des réseaux sociaux
et de l'instantanéité et de l'éphémère
et du coup c'est c'est c'est le moment
c'est
le moment politique ça ressemble
davantage à des spasmes qu'à autre chose
voyez c'est c'est une espèce de
spasmodie
politique et je partage votre point de
vue sur la sur la radicalisation ça ça
ça marche dans les deux sens d'ailleurs
et mais il faut bien voir aussi il faut
alors naturellement les émeutes se sont
transformés en pillage les pillages ont
choqué la population à juste titre mais
le point de départ de tout ça c'est
quand même un sentiment d'injustice de
la part d'une partie de la population
sur les contrôles de police et la
relation et la relation avec la police
ça fait partie des réponses de fond qui
va bien falloir apporter à un moment et
je voulais dire en disant pour l'instant
la première réponse est sécuritaire et
elle est légitimement sécuritaire je
pense que tout le monde autour de de
cette table sera d'accord mais il va
falloir une autre réponse quand même
allez-y il y a une réponse financière
aussi qui arrive avec le projet de loi
entre guillemets urgence à la
reconstruction qui devrait être assez
consensuel ça devrait passer
moi personnellement je pense que ça va
être voté mais ça va pas être aussi
simple alors là où ils sont très forts
c'est que quand on regarde le projet de
loi c'est ce sont trois articles mais
trois d'ordonnance donc quand on fait
des ordonnances on peut très peu amender
on peut juste amender en rétrécissant le
champ donc on peut voilà l'opposition va
pas pouvoir dire je veux rajouter si je
veux rajouter ça donc le débat va
réussir à être assez court grâce au
choix encore une fois du véhicule
législatif d'accord qui a fait le
gouvernement mais je ne vois pas
l'opposition comme elle est fit laissez
passer ça ça va être une rétribune de
dire le vrai problème n'est pas là c'est
pas l'argent qu'on demande c'est la
question des violences policières sur le
taxi etc est-ce qu'ils vont utiliser une
motion est-ce qu'ils police on connaît
l'argumentaire de la France insoumise
alors écoutez ce sera à suivre dans les
dans les prochains jours et notamment
sur les chaînes parlementaires
franchement elle parmi les événements
marquants de l'année alors vous aviez
encore une fois on vous en je vous ai
demandé donnez-nous en plusieurs pour
pouvoir qu'on ne parle pas que d'un seul
thème vous avez choisi ce moment
regardez
alors comme vous l'imaginez je suis
évidemment très ému ce soir et je ne
peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée
pour la première femme qui a occupé ses
fonctions et dites cresson et peut-être
je voudrais dédier cette nomination à
toutes les petites filles en leur disant
allez au bout de vos rêves et rien ne
doit freiner le combat pour la place des
femmes dans notre société voilà les
premières minutes d'Elizabeth borne à
Matignon Franck Morel quel bilan
faites-vous de son action le bilan il
est totalement phagocyté par la séquence
réforme des retraites donc il est pas
évident à faire de ce point de vue là je
pense qu'on aura un peu plus de recul si
Elisabeth borne remplit entre guillemets
à Matignon pour faire un bilan mais ce
qui est intéressant de souligner c'est
que et c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs j'ai cité cet événement comme
l'un des deux événements marquants de
l'année c'est que Emmanuel Macron au
début de chacun de ces deux quinquennat
a choisi
par le choix de son premier ministre de
prendre des décisions qui sortent de
l'ordinaire au début du premier
quinquennat il a pour la première fois
nommé quelqu'un qui ne l'avait pas
officiellement soutenu
lors des élections présidentielles ce
qui n'était jamais arrivé dans
l'histoire de la 5e République et lors
son second quinquennat il nomme à
nouveau alors que ça n'était pas arrivé
depuis 1991 une femme à Matignon et en
plus en surprenant puisque il y a eu
avant la séquence Catherine Vautrin
effectivement qui s'est terminé comme on
le sait
annoncé pour devenir
et puis malheureusement pour elle
effectivement qui n'a pas pu aller
jusqu'au bout du processus et donc c'est
un point qui est notable parce que il y
avait une très forte demande de la part
de beaucoup d'acteurs dans dans le monde
politique et même de la part d'une large
part de l'opinion publique pour qu'une
femme revienne enfin à Matignon après de
nombreuses années effectivement passées
depuis la fin de la séquence Ed et donc
il a choisi effectivement de satisfaire
cette demande très très forte alors
après une fois qu'on a dit ça ça
n'enlève rien à toutes les difficultés
qu'a connues et Elisabeth borne avec le
contexte de majorité relative avec le
fait que son premier chantier a été le
chantier des réformes des retraites avec
toutes les difficultés qu'on lui qu'on
connaît un chantier et qui ont connu
chantier mais c'est un point qui est
notable alors quand même sur le destin
d'Elisabeth borne regardez ce sondage
sondage odoxa pour Le Figaro publié en
cette fin d'après-midi de jeudi
Elisabeth borde doit-elle rester
première ministre le OUI à 34% le nom à
65% Jean-Louis CICAT celles et ceux qui
souhaitent un changement de Premier
ministre risque-t-il d'être déçu je
pense que oui
je pense que oui parce que je vois pas
très bien
[Musique]
Emmanuel Macron est dans une impasse
mais c'est une impasse politique que
l'on connaît pratiquement depuis les
élections de juin 2022 il n'a pas de ma
à l'Assemblée nationale et la seule
formation politique avec laquelle il
pourrait avoir
absolu il a une majorité relative il n'a
pas de majorité absolue il faut pour
voter les lois il faut une majoritaire
absolue et sauf si vous utilisez 49-3
mais enfin bon visiblement c'est
compliqué on a une spécialiste à tout à
l'heure du bilan parlementaire on va
dire de
donc je vais pas m'aventurer sur ce
terrain là non ce que par contre le seul
parti politique avec lequel il pourrait
passer une alliance les républicains et
je pense que ça c'est un événement
marquant de l'année 2023 a pris une
décision majeure avec leur conférence de
presse conjointe la D3 des 3 leaders à
propos de l'immigration a pris une
décision majeure qui est de donner un
coup de barre non pas à droite mais à
l'extrême droite et donc ça si vous
voulez ça crée une situation où par
exemple nommer Darmanin Premier ministre
mais pour faire quoi il est incapable
aujourd'hui de nouer une alliance avec
les républicains donc à quoi ça
servirait alors ce sera un signal sur
l'autorité l'ordre etc mais enfin il y a
il y a une impossibilité et donc c'est
pourquoi je pense qu'Elizabeth borne a
de bonnes chances quelle que soit la
qualité de ses relations avec Emmanuel
Macron de rester à Matignon encore
quelques temps le gouvernement qui vit
depuis des semaines avec les rumeurs de
maniement Laetitia vous avez choisi de
nous parler du ministre de l'éducation
nationale sur la sellette depuis des
semaines il a choisi une communication
offensive ces derniers jours la comme de
la dernière chance en quelque sorte oui
on peut l'analyser comme ça en fait
c'est une stratégie qui a été choisie
c'est de faire du clash pour se défendre
c'est un peu celle cette stratégie celle
de sa collègue à la culture Rima Abdul
Malak je ne sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais fin juin quand la grève au
Journal du Dimanche a commencé elle
avait tweeté un matin dimanche matin en
disant qu'elle regrettait avec son café
du dimanche de ne pas avoir le JDD et
puis elle avait ajouté cette phrase en
droit le JDD peut devenir ce qu'il veut
tant qu'il respecte la loi mais pour nos
valeurs républicaines comment ne pas
s'alarer alors ce tweet avait beaucoup
de remous dans la classe politique était
remonté à l'Élysée pourquoi Thomas c'est
quand même la ministre de tutelle qui se
permet de critiquer parce que c'est une
critique la nomination de Geoffroy plus
jeune transfuge du magazine valeur
actuelle à la tête de la de la rédaction
du Journal du dimanche
quand même puisque sur radiologie pas
bendiaye a affirmé que cnews et Europe 1
était de médias d'extrême droite donc
ces deux médias du groupe Bolloré
étaient des médias d'extrême droite et
alors ça rend quand même
bouclier à droite à l'Assemblée
nationale il a été questionné sur ses
propos et puis au Sénat hier écoutez
comment le ministre répond il est droit
dans ses potes
il est de mon droit le plus strict de
donner un point de vue sur la ligne
éditoriale d'une chaîne de télévision il
ne s'agit pas de censurer qui que ce
soit si monsieur le sénateur vous aviez
écouté mon interview dans sa durée sur
les grands chantiers de l'éducation
nationale vous m'auriez interrogé sur la
parentalité l'implication des parents
dans la squarly dans la scolarité des
enfants vous m'auriez interrogé sur
l'orientation des élèves avec la
découverte des métiers vous m'auriez
interrogé sur la réforme du bac et les
pistes de travail pour la réforme du
troisième trimestre vous m'auriez
interrogé sur la question du niveau en
français
c'est ça alors parce que ça continue on
l'a coupé c'était trop bon pour pour il
fait son bilan quoi il fait tout son
bilan c'est-à-dire que ça répond c'est
qu'il maintient quand même il faut
reconnaître ses propos sur sa news et au
repas et il fait 100 bilan comme si
alors comme si il était il y avait déjà
un pied dehors et qu'il dressait
lui-même son bilan
il sait qu'il est pas en odeur de santé
à l'Élysée on le sait nous on a eu ce
poétiques on entend hein ces rumeurs
d'une Brigitte Macron qui aurait lâché
pas pendji dans l'Emmanuel Macron dont
c'était le choix premier quand même qui
se s'interroge sur bon le côté
emblématique c'était pour ça qu'il avait
choisi au départ et puis finalement il
s'est fait piquer tous ces dossiers je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
l'origine Macron a lui a pris le
harcèlement scolaire Emmanuel Macron lui
a pris l'enseignement professionnel donc
finalement pas pendial c'est dit je vais
faire du clash pourquoi pour être
invirable et pourquoi parce qu'il s'il
est finalement écarté on dira il a été
écarté à cause de ses propos mais pas
pas à cause de ça cette communication
elle tranche quand même avec le le style
qui était le sien qui était plutôt un
style on va dire mais de haute chez
plutôt profil bas ah bah complètement
c'est-à-dire que je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez de sa première son premier
déplacement c'était avec Emmanuel Macron
il était chaproné à Marseille il avait
pas dit un seul mot et puis ensuite il
avait tenu cette ligne de communication
quasi mythique c'est quand même
paradoxal pour une communication mais
c'était c'était la sienne et là pourquoi
sur le papier cette stratégie du clash
est pertinente pourquoi parce que c'est
justement le moment où tous les
projecteurs sont braqués sur le ministre
de l'éducation nationale il sait qu'il
est fragilisé et si encore une fois il
est écarté l'opinion publique pourra
être témoin de l'éviction également du
ministre de gauche je vous rappelle
quand même qu'il y a de la gauche que
c'était emblématique et puis lui
finalement pourra dire que c'était à
cause de son courage politique de son
maître de face aux médias d'extrême
droite finalement donc on aura viré en
gros je vous fais la il a reçu le
soutien d'Emmanuel Macron enfin en tout
cas ce sont les infos qui nous sont
remontées c'est pour ça que je me dis
que cette stratégie est quand même
plutôt efficace parce que hier en
conseil des ministres Emmanuel Macron a
fait savoir qu'il soutenait pas peine et
son entourage n'arrête pas de
d'alimenter à la presse les médias les
journalistes avec cette phrase oui à la
liberté d'expression mais oui à la
critique de l'exercice de la liberté de
la presse oui à la liberté de la presse
mais oui à la critique de la liberté de
la presse et dans le Figaro donc on
comprend que Manuel Macron soutient pas
à suivre évidemment Jean-Louis Sica
c'est un clash pour se sauver ou tout
simplement moi quand je l'ai entendu je
me suis dit il sait qu'il va sans doute
être exciltré donc ils disent qu'il
pense
vous me demandez d'être dans la tête de
papel je suis absolument incapable je
pense qu'il a dit ce qu'il pensait oui
mais peut-être aussi qu'il y avait un
calcul politique derrière vous savez
quand un homme politique s'exprime c'est
toujours pareil il y a il y a de la
sincérité il y a de la conviction mais
il y a aussi du calcul donc par
définition très rarement à ce niveau
complètement spontané
le type de propos en plus mais bon en
même temps quand il dit qu'il a le droit
de le dire même en tant que ministre je
crois qu'il a parfaitement raison si
jamais on n'a pas le droit aujourd'hui
de dire que c'est news ou Europe 1 sont
des médias d'extrême droite où va-t-on
dans ce pays quoi donc chacun a son
opinion il y a je respecte tout à fait
les opinions de ceux qui disent que ce
ne sont pas des des médias d'extrême
droite tout simplement j'aimerais bien
entendre des arguments alors vous vous
dit tout à l'heure qu'il y avait
finalement assez peu de texte qui était
passé en dehors du 49-3 alors malgré
l'absence de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier Véran a tenu à
rappeler le contraire chiffres en main
écoutant le
alors que nous sommes en situation de
majorité relative 47 textes auront été
adoptés en un an par le Parlement pour
les deux tiers d'entre eux quasiment il
s'agit d'initiative parlementaire ce qui
montre que notre démocratie
parlementaire se porte bien et nous le
saluons
alors on va on va discuter des chiffres
un terme traduit bonjour bienvenue
bonjour quel est le bilan de cette
activité législative depuis un an alors
si on fait le bilan on peut distinguer
trois temps ou plutôt 3 catégories de
textes il y a eu les textes où la
stratégie de construire une majorité
texte par texte n'a pas trop mal marché
ensuite vous avez une deuxième catégorie
bien ce sont les textes budgétaires bien
sûr ceux de l'automne loi de finances
2023 budget de la Sécurité sociale qui
ont été adoptés à coup de 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale il en a fallu pas
moins de 10 pour que Elisabeth borne
fasse adopter ses textes c'était devenu
sa petite routine de l'automne dernier
et puis il y a eu bien sûr la réforme
des retraites le grand crash elle aussi
finalement adoptée par 49-3 mais pour le
coup très contesté par l'opposition et
par une bonne partie des Français dans
son sillage il y a eu donc une grande
victime collatérale ce projet doit sur
l'immigration que l'on n'en finit pas
d'attendre retirer de l'ordre du jour
par souci d'apaisement l'apaisement
c'est d'ailleurs le slogan des 100 jours
qui s'achève et le gouvernement qui a
quand même réussi à construire quelques
majorités de projets autour de certains
textes parce qu'on l'a dit avec un
canard a commencé avec une nouvelle
donne une mauvaise nouvelle pour le
président de la République la majorité
relative à l'Assemblée malgré ça
l'activité n'a pas été paralysée alors
sur la session ce ne sont pas 47 lois
qui ont été adoptées mais promulgués par
le Président de la République et il y a
eu 29 projets de loi qui ont été
définitivement adoptés alors tantôt avec
le concours de la droite c'est le cas de
la réforme de l'assurance chômage ou
encore de la loi locmi sur les moyens du
ministère de l'Intérieur tantôt avec le
concours de la gauche la loi sur les
énergies renouvelables tantôt avec le
concours de la droite et d'une partie de
la gauche c'était le cas pour la relance
du nucléaire avec des voix et l'air et
des voix communiste à l'Assemblée et
puis il y a eu 25 propositions loi qui
ont été adoptées dont 10 d'origine
sénatoriale parmi elles il y a eu bien
sûr des textes très consensuels comme la
proposition de loi pour apporter une
aide d'urgence aux victimes de violences
con et puis des textes un peu moins
consensuel un dernier texte adopté en
date c'était ce matin la proposition de
loi sur le zéro artificialisation nette
énorme sujet de préoccupation pour les
élus locaux pour qui la mise en oeuvre
de cet objectif vire parfois au
casse-tête et si on s'intéresse d'un peu
plus près aux deux chambres le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale en fonctionné
différemment oui de chambre deux
ambiances l'assemblée survolté au bord
de la crise de nerf le Sénat toujours
plus feutré avec ses échanges à fleurer
moucheté c'est un peu caricatural mais
c'est pas loin de la réalité principale
différence avec la session précédente
bien sûr qu'on est passé d'une assemblée
largement dominée par la République en
marche complètement acquise au
gouvernement à une majorité relative
beaucoup plus difficile à maîtriser du
coup le Sénat qui était le
contre-pouvoir qui était boudé par le
gouvernement sous Macron 1 et devenu un
allié potentiel à qui on parle plus
volontiers à les ministres ont trouvé
d'un coup les numéros de portable des
sénateurs qui nous ont raconté pour
certains être oui voilà les temps
changent mais il y a tout de même une
chose qui ne change pas du tout au Sénat
c'est toujours la capacité à faire des
commissions d'enquête qui est triste
très poliment mais qui est trié quand
même le gouvernement il y a eu bien sûr
la faire Benalla les cabinets de
conseils sous le premier mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron et cette fois-ci il y
a eu la commission d'enquête sur le fond
Marianne qui a dénoncé je cite le titre
de cette de ce rapport la dérive d'un
coup politique de Marlène Schiappa la
ministre avait dit d'ailleurs au début
souhaiter cette commission d'enquête
avant qu'elle débute l'histoire ne dit
pas si elle le pense toujours oui
effectivement merci beaucoup Tom trahi
pour ce bilan
parlementaire et évidemment je me tourne
vers vous mélodie mogwe
qu'est-ce qui ressort au-delà des textes
sur finalement le fonctionnement de
notre cinquième république quelle leçon
vous en tirer alors déjà en fait c'est
la première fois alors il y a déjà une
majorité relative mais c'est la première
fois qu'on ne majorité relative après la
réforme de 2008 qui a renforcé les
droits de l'opposition donc il y a un
rapport de ce qui est déjà différent de
1988 on voit vraiment que le
gouvernement perd du terrain de façon
très concrète en tout cas à l'Assemblée
sur l'ordre du jour beaucoup plus de
propositions noirs inscrites à l'ordre
du jour que des projets de loi le nombre
d'amendements 730 amendements déposés
alors qu'il y en avait à peu près 780
sur la même période sur l'ancienne
législature là il y en a que 323 qui
sont adoptés alors que 90% avaient été
adoptés sous l'ancienne législature donc
moins de la moitié d'adoption
d'amendements par le gouvernement donc
ça veut dire qu'il perd en pouvoir en
force et même sur les projets de loi il
y a un nombre presque similaire de
projet de loi là on avait enfin on a
donné des projets de loi importants mais
il y a beaucoup de projets lois traités
donc des simples traités d'applications
donc en réalité il a une fosse activité
législatante pas du tout en fait on voit
juste les rapports de il y a autant
d'activités législatives on fait
toujours autant de loi donc d'ailleurs
on peut se poser la question de
l'inflation législative
mais mais ça différemment voilà et il y
a une fragilité du gouvernement qu'on
voit dans les chiffres en tout cas dans
les statistiques et même dans les débats
et avec un fonctionnement différent on
voit des alliances de circonstances à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'on voyait pas
des amendements qui peuvent passer quand
on est dans l'opposition avec et les
filles et RN et l'air et compagnie qui
vont le voter alors attention il y a
moins d'amendements votez sous cette
léchature que que la dernière fois donc
c'est un peu surprenant mais c'est pas
la même le même contenu voilà est-ce que
je peux juste les mettre une hypothèse
dans le changement de fonctionnement il
y a l'entrée de la médiatisation dans
tout ce fonctionnement jamais les débats
l'assemblée non donnés autant de bruit
médiatique de reprise médiatique en fait
les médias ont feu étonné donc ça fait
une chambre déco troisième chambre celle
là et qui est très très très très très
importante pour les retomber dans
l'opinion est-ce que c'est la validation
de la stratégie LFI ça d'une certaine
façon franchement il y a une question
qu'on peut se poser par rapport au bilan
que vous venez de brosser de de
l'activité législative c'est est-ce que
la séquence réforme des retraites va
changer ou pas les choses par rapport à
une approche qu'on pouvait qualifier de
pragmatique de votre texte par texte qui
a pu se dérouler très tranquillement
avec évidemment toutes les difficultés
que vous allez mentionner un lié à
l'existence du majoritérative mais qui a
permis comme cela a été présenté tout à
l'heure l'adoption d'un certain nombre
de textes est-ce que la vie entre
guillemets telle que je viens de la
décrire va reprendre son cours dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent ou
est-ce que la séquence réforme des
retraites aura changé quelque chose d'un
point de vue politique dans l'appétence
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs et je
pense en particulier aux républicains
qui ont quand même mis en avant au grand
jour à travers cette séquence une
division assez importante au sein du
groupe républicain est-ce que ça ça va
se matérialiser politiquement ou est-ce
que après un laps de temps et bien on va
revenir un petit peu au fonctionnement
texte par texte tel qu'on l'a connu on
peut se poser la question
une question pour la gauche exactement
comme la Nupe c'est en train de se
déliter que les européennes arrivent et
que là on va avoir quand même un
affrontement entre les différentes
forces de gauche il est possible là de
ce point de vue que les choses soient
différentes pour le Parti socialiste
pour Europe Écologie les vagues et aussi
pour le petit parti charnière là je me
j'ai oublié comment il s'appelle oui
ça peut changer un tout petit peu la
donne aussi donc vous me dites que les
leçons de la première année du second
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron seront pas
forcément les mêmes pour la seconde
année que l'équilibre de l'Assemblée
nationale va peut-être un peu sur le
républicain quand même on a l'impression
que la leçon qu'ils ont tiré du fiasco
de la réforme des retraites puisque ils
avaient l'intention de voter ce texte et
ils n'ont pas été en capacité de le
faire il faut bien dire les choses comme
comme elles sont la leçon qu'ils ont
tiré c'est de en quelque sorte faire
faire bouger le centre de gravité
politique
grande partie vers l'extrême droite et
donc ça ça ferme la porte logiquement à
toute négociation à tout compromis mais
en réalité
c'est quand même 60 députés qui chacun
vote un peu comme il l'entend et qui
peuvent voter des textes au cas par cas
mélodie déjà on a vu Laurent Wauquiez
quand même faire une belle interview
dans le Figaro dans un timing quand même
un petit peu le président de la
République ne s'exprime pas lui
s'exprime il ne s'était pas exprimé
pendant les retraites
au sein du des républicains
mais vraiment on sortait dans la rue je
pense pas que non bien sûr mais mais ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que
ça c'est déporté vers la fin quand on
voit Éric Ciotti Retailleau et compagnie
c'est déporté bien à droite quand on
regarde l'interview de Laurent Wauquiez
il tend plutôt la main à au président de
grand public et à Gérald Darmanin et
on l'a revenu trois grands thèmes
immigration sécurité méritocratie il y a
des excusez-moi ce qui est intéressant
c'est quand même de voir dans cet
exercice de communication quand même qui
est celui mis en musique par Laurent
Wauquiez qui va refiler le mistigri à
l'autre on va dire les choses comme ça
du refus de l'union sacrée entre
guillemets parce que on voit bien que
Laurent Wauquiez met sur la table un
certain nombre de propositions dont il
sait que pour partie au moins
elles ne vont pas être reprises par la
majorité et dans l'autre sens on voit
bien que l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles le projet de loi immigration
ne peut pas avancer comme le reste était
la majorité c'est parce que au sein de
ce projet de loi il y a une partie qui
n'est pas acceptée précisément par la
République 1 qui est la question des
métiers en tension et donc on voit bien
que derrière cet exercice de
communication il y a le renvoi du
Mistigri en gros moi je veux l'union
sacrée c'est toi qui la veux pas et on
le voit bien donc quand Laurent Wauquiez
propose cette union sacrée ou quand le
gouvernement met en avant justement un
certain nombre d'idées sur le sur
l'immigration oui juste pour ajouter
peut-être aussi de Laurent Wauquiez
parce que je vous recommande son
interview dans le point où il parle de
l'État profond et où il tient des propos
que ne désavourez pas un Donald Trump et
que la question c'est c'est de quelle
leur ont voté nous parlons exactement
après sur le groupe les républicains
déjà sous l'ancienne législature on
avait l'impression qu'il y avait c'était
déjà un découpage c'est à dire qu'il y
avait ce qu'on appelle les Macron
compatibles qui sont qui se disent
droites responsable de gouvernement ceux
qui ne savent pas en fonction du texte
par texte et ceux qui étaient dans une
opposition frontale souvent un premier
mandat sauf qu'ils étaient sans donc ça
ça choquait moins et puis ils arrivaient
à basculer à 80 votes sur 20 là à 60
surtout qu'on sait que parfois il manque
cinq voix ça change tout un dernier mot
Franck Morel il y a quand même une force
d'attraction au sein de la majorité pour
une partie de CLR on peut citer Édouard
Philippe Gérald Darmanin Brunet enfin
bon voilà est-ce qu'il y a un risque
l’implosion tout simplement puisqu'on
essaye de se projeter là dans le dans
l'année à venir mais forcé de constater
que un des éléments explicatifs ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur les 60
députés sur le fait que on a vu tous les
gammes de couleurs on va dire dans les
positions qui ont été adoptées un des
éléments explicatifs c'est quand même la
sociologie des électorats dans leur
circuits bien sûr dans leur
circonscriptions contre ils ont gagné au
second qu'ils ont gagné effectivement
contre le RN ça sous leur contrôleur
parfois dans d'autres contextes
effectivement et ça ça peut être un
élément de décryptage des choix
stratégiques différents entre ceux qui
poussent plutôt pour une ligne très à
droite et puis ceux qui vont pousser
pour se rapprocher comme Nicolas Sarkozy
on se rapprochait de la majorité il est
pas impossible qu'effectivement avant la
fin du quinquennat ça se traduit par une
scission oui c'est les paris sont
ouverts merci à tous on a fait des merci
dans ce débat merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat politique en
vacances mais merci encore 45 minutes
juste après avec un débat passionnant
Jean-Louis Messika j'envoie évidemment
au site la grande conversation et votre
livre mélodie mcgowell petit guide de
l'amendement d'édition pépère et
l'harmattant à très bientôt sur sur
public c'est là